[Music]
hi everyone hope you are enjoying the
show so far
my name is mathias young game director
on horizon forbidden west i'm here today
to share some exciting news on our
upcoming sequel it's been a few months
since we at gorilla were able to share
our first gameplay experience as part of
playstation state of play giving you a
glimpse of where aylor's journey will
take her next and showcasing exciting
new elements like swimming free climbing
expanded melee combat and more
at that time horizon forbidden west had
just passed a major milestone and we had
ended the final stage of development on
track but a bit uncertain if we would be
able to polish the game to the level of
quality that we strive for
it's no surprise that our teams were
hugely impacted by the global pandemic
we've been adjusting to new workflows
and other challenges while keeping our
team safe and prioritizing a healthy
work-life balance but today we can
finally confirm that our long-awaited
sequel will come to both playstation 4
and playstation 5 on the 18th of
february 2022
and look for pre-orders to start next
week on the 2nd of september we're so
grateful to you our amazing fans for
your unwavering support we know how much
you're looking forward to reuniting with
eloy and her friends continuing her
story and exploring a new and dangerous
world your passion fan art cosplay
virtual photography and videos have
meant the world to all of us
before we go there's one more thing to
share with you and it's something our
community has been asking about for a
while now
the patch for 60 fps support for horizon
zero dawn on playstation 5 is live right
now and you can find more information on
our social channels from all of us at
the gorilla and playstation thank you
for all your support and enjoy the rest
of this show